this wedding news though is gwen stefani
and blake shelton yay they tied the knot
over the weekend big yay
they exchanged the vows in an intimate
ceremony at shelton's ranch you know he
lives in oklahoma
in a chapel that he reportedly built
right there on the estate
now the two have been together for
nearly six years and i spoke with them
uh last year a couple years ago with
gwen and blake uh for a grammy special
that we were doing we
started talking about their relationship
and then the lady then also the song
comes on the radio
i feel like i'm the one that's like
getting it all by getting blake you know
what i'm saying what the hell is
the truth everybody is jealous of me too
i'm a little jealous of you you know my
boyfriend's daughter's also jealous big
blake
no i oh no listen i i think they're both
really terrific but after that interview
it was so sweet
they were leaving and we were behind
them they didn't know that we were
behind them
and you know how when when a guy you're
a couple and he puts his hand in your
pocket
and she they had their hands in each
other's pocket she said blakey that was
so nice you said so many nice things
about me
and he goes but i love you baby i love
you and they didn't know that we were
behind and i did just when you did
oh that's so sweet so i know so it's so
great that they tied the knot over the
weekends
congratulations congrats